[Music]
[Applause]
all right i'll get your phone calls
coming up let's bring in david carr nfl
network analyst former nfl quarterback
is uh he joining us uh fritzi
david's all set david is there david
thanks for joining us um let me start
with this whole philosophy of rookie
quarterbacks and let's put in somebody
who has athleticism if we don't have a
good offensive line
i'm looking at the numbers that you
suffered through when you first came
into the league you had athleticism
probably didn't have a good offensive
line
what does that do for your confidence
level
i'm torn man because i see i see like
for instance
justin fields in chicago right we talked
about and i kind of heard your intro
with josh allen and getting the mvp
chance and andy dalton on the other end
getting booed off the field before he
even throws his first pass so it's like
you're either the mvp or the worst in
the league and i'm like
do we want to put justin fields behind
the chicago bears offensive line that
i've watched for the last three weeks
absolutely not
and just because i've been in that
situation before
yeah justin okay you have to ask
yourself a question if you're a bearish
fan justin fields in this day and age
has the opportunity to play quarterback
for you guys for the next 15 years right
so do you want to risk that
by throwing him into a situation where
yes athletically he can survive the
situation
but he's already shown
the ability and
honestly to
his default is going to be to move it's
always going to be to move and and make
a play with his legs because he's always
been able to do that so he's going to
revert back to that when situations suck
and in with the chicago bears the way
they're set up right now
he's not going to develop into the
pastor that he maybe could be if he's
out there developing really bad habits
and i know because i've done it and i
was in that situation where
you know you're you're in the
quarterback room
and the quarterback coach is saying hey
you just gotta just gotta buy some time
right here just just trust the receivers
let their routes develop
i break the meeting i walk down the
hallway the offensive line coach grabs
he puts his arm around me says dave we
got to find a way to get the ball out of
our hand faster and i'm like okay
i'm 21 years old who do i listen to you
know so that's like that's the situation
justin's going to be in
is
the offensive lines coat offensive line
coach is going to say hey let's get the
ball to our hands let's find a way to
run get out of there
and and matt and aggie and those guys
are going to be trying to get him to
develop into the past that they wanted
to be now
you can you can kind of do both russell
wilson and justin have very similar
traits when i watched russell play early
on
they couldn't keep him off the field
remember matt i think matt flynn was
there
russell went in he made plays
dynamically with his legs and he was
able to
kind of develop into that passer
as he was working through running with
the ball and being smart and sliding and
taking care of his body now he's he's a
rare breed that guy's a tremendous
talent you know and justin is also but
russell was able to work through that
and become the pastor that he is now
still with the threat to run so
it's just man the odds aren't in your
favor if you just throw a guy out there
and try to have him just survive because
you're not very good i just i'm not for
it i'd love to see justin play for a
long time and have great success
you know playing quarterback and then
using his legs when he has to
um not because
he's just absolutely in an emergency
situation every time yeah and you're
going to revert back to what you do well
and that is that you want to be athletic
and make a play extend to play whereas
mac jones is behind an offensive line
that's really good and will be protected
better trey lance will be behind a
better offensive line he'll be better
protected um i think that's the
difference here is justin fields if he
was with the patriots or with the niners
then you could say hey you don't have to
try to make a play uh you know
we'll pick and pick our spots web design
running plays but trying to handicap
this and with uh
it's different quarterbacks different
situations it's not this blanket you got
to throw the rookie out there and and
let him play like zach wilson
i i don't know what i mean i would be
nervous if i'm a jets fan that zack
wilson is going out there we don't have
a legitimate backup our offensive line
has not been good
and i'm sending the kid out there into
battle
yeah i'm with you and i think the
man every situation is different and
like for zach wilson
you know what i've seen in the preseason
has been fantastic you guys been great
on the money downs like i don't care
really what you do on first and second
down that's easy you know that's what
you should be able to do and that's a
lot of it's on your offensive
coordinator and they've done a good job
um
in new york just what i've seen so far
in the first couple weeks but what he's
been great on is in third down standing
in the pocket making throws corey davis
um utilizing his his arm strength he
just kind of whipped the ball to the
sideline just effortlessly off of plays
that are kind of broken
so i see all the ability there for zach
wilson no question about it
i think to your point the only thing
that i could say
is that offensive scheme is going to be
such where they're going to utilize you
know it's it's just like kyle shanahan
and sean mcvay these guys are going to
move the pocket a lot so it's not
necessarily a situation that i see in
chicago where chicago doesn't really
they're not really that good at it like
matt and aggie should be you know being
the chief system and having that ability
but his offense has always left me like
man where's this dynamic ability at
um to to create offense for your
quarterback and i haven't seen that i i
think i have seen that so far with what
they're going to do with the jet so i
feel a little bit better about that
situation
um
not great but i feel a little bit better
about it because when they do to ask him
to take shots down the field or hold the
ball it's going to be where he's on the
move and he can kind of protect himself
and and to your point they don't have
anybody else like they don't i i just
don't see like i mean bring a veteran in
like having
having to be able to watch a kid you
know watch a guy go through it for the
first couple weeks you know that would
be a lot better situation in my opinion
but
thematically i feel better about the jet
situation i do about chicago he's david
carr you can follow nfl network analyst
david carr on twitter at d car eight
what's the meanest thing you've said
about your brother's performance
i'm old school man so like
well i try to i try to he he has to be
smart you got to be smart as a
quarterback
and for me i used to lift with the
offensive lineman i used to want to run
over everybody i used to want to play
the game physical just for the respect
of my
teammates you know that was it and
for derek he is he is so tapped in like
he's at another level as far as
understanding where to go football how
to find a completion instantly and
gruden preaches it nonstop like
completions completions completions this
guy just sent me i mean this is probably
not doesn't need to be public knowledge
but he completed 95 of his passes in
team drills through training camp 95
when peyton manning needs to talk about
peyton would complete like 85 percent
and gruden challenged him with that and
he sent me a text yesterday i said 95 so
the guy is like
he's going to find a completion and
john's going to preach that and i i wish
that they would allow him to push the
ball down the field a little bit more
and it's not it's not really derek it's
just john's scheme
you know they're gonna just find a way
to get the ball in their playmakers
hands and they're they're top ten
they're gonna be top ten this year
they're wildly efficient but he's always
had the ability to understand coverage
diagnose it and and take advantage and
take chunks out of guys you know and and
opponents but when are you ripping him
when are you ripping him david
i don't i mean i don't really rip him
because i at this point he plays
fantastic football i mean he's not going
to be
he's not going to do these crazy dynamic
things like
josh allen or patrick mahomes just you
know running backwards throwing these
crazy he's going to be very clean he
thinks peyton manning's the greatest
quarterback of all time he tries to
emulate that guy you know he's going to
run when he has to but he understands
that his uh
mental ability to understand and break
down coverage and throw the football
accurately is more important so i wish i
could see a little bit more like just
kind of loose
dynamic play from him because i know
he's a great athlete you know that's
just me as a brother kind of wanting to
be able to do that because he's a better
athlete than me and i wish i could use
his ability but he's going to play the
way he plays and he plays fine for john
and they play great so
it's hard to nitpick man he doesn't
didn't turn the football over he doesn't
he doesn't make any negative plays i
mean the really the only thing that i
that i can say is i wish that we could
push the ball down the field a little
bit more you know but it's i mean they
they do it's just that's just me eli
manning was on a podcast with lavar
arrington and he was talking about how
you know jordan love is he the answer
and
eli said to lavar arrington uh that's
kind of me reading between the lines if
i think he was the answer or if
ownership thought he was the answer
rogers would be gone rogers probably
knows that he's not the answer also so
he could kind of play that hand a little
bit
quarterbacks know if a quarterback can
play right
yeah yeah yeah and almost instantly
almost instantly yeah so i i have to
believe aaron rodgers knew the packers
weren't comfortable turning over the
keys to this you know nfc title team
to jordan love they just didn't know
therefore rogers had the ultimate
bargaining power and probably still does
though david because
he's probably saying jordan loves not
the answer without coming out and saying
it what do you think of what eli is
alluding to
well you know
you can watch i my boys make fun of me
all the time i got
21 18 and 16. we watch football games
and i'll watch a guy for two plays and
say no he's not it's a high school kid
or college that's not it right and
they're like no come on give him a
chance he's he's a
five-star recruit he's going to go i'm
like he's not it right maybe he will be
but not right now right so that's
exactly right that's it aaron has
aaron has all the power now jordan love
has been in my backyard 100 feet from
where i am right now working out with me
i've known him forever he's from this
area from bakersfield california went to
liberty high school
known him since he was yeah little kid
and i love jordan but jordan's not aaron
rodgers and aaron rodgers knows that
he's not aaron rodgers and so i have all
the pull
and i can i can run this thing and is
jordan going to be a fine player someday
can you be a starting quarterback
absolutely we've watched him play in the
pre-season he's
he even looks the part he's kind of
developed some of aaron's mannerisms i
love quarterbacks they're in the same
room kind of watch each other they kind
of look the same you know and they all
emulate the starting quarterback but
join another team a little bit should
another team have taken jordan love
well i mean that's
yeah i don't think the packers should
have that's just crazy because you're
you're you're sitting on the uh on the
cusp of
going to a super bowl you're you're
right there on the doorstep
and your decision is
another quarterback i mean it just makes
zero sense to me just zero cents
so yeah another team should have taken
jordan when the packers took jordan
everyone here is excited and i'm sitting
there like why would they do that this
is just going to be a disaster like it's
going to be he's not going to play
aaron's going to be upset
it's just going to be a bad situation go
get another guy to help you win a super
bowl try to get over the hump and beat
the 49ers and get to get to the big the
big game you know so yeah they shouldn't
have taken him they did and that's where
they're at so it's it's their mess they
got to clean it up aaron's aaron's in
the driver's seat he goes out there he's
going to
probably be pushing to be mvp again
because their offense is great you got
devonta adams they're going to run the
ball well matt leflore is a genius and
they'll be they'll be fine you know the
defense will play a little bit better
um but yeah they they're just that's the
situation they made you know now you got
to live with it
which quarterback would you want this
year justin herbert or matthew stafford
oh man that's a tough one um i get
nervous about the chargers not just
because i don't say this just because
during the fc west and i want them to be
terrible and let me let my raiders win
but i get nervous about them just
because of joe lombardi and i'm not
saying he's a bad coordinator but he had
a chance in detroit it wasn't great he
went back to new orleans and he i mean
sean payton's brilliant in new orleans
but let's not give everybody credit that
comes from new orleans that they're
going to be great so i get i'm a little
hesitant there but
he's a tremendous talent um
i don't know man i'm a big fan of matt
stafford i always have been i always put
in my top 10 list everybody always gives
me crap for it
just because he plays for detroit i mean
you guys tough he wants to play in big
games he's got all the ability to do it
i love him with the rams i mean they're
going to be they're going to be right
there man they're going to be in the
championship game you can almost pencil
them in for that you know just leave the
talent on the defensive side what they
have on offense i'm not saying that you
don't you don't want to take away
anything away from jared goff that's the
other thing that i i mean jared goff got
you to the super bowl he played good
football he's one of the better
intermediate pastors in the league the
thing that they needed to do internally
they looked at when they got in trouble
when when
his system runs into a trouble sean
mcvay it's when you get extra pressure
and you're not able to beat it with some
smoke and mirrors with these jet sweeps
with just getting the ball quick to
cooper cup and robert woods with not
being able to beat with play action when
you have to stand in the pocket make
reads and decisions and you have extra
defenders coming at you you have to you
have to be accurate quick throw from
different angles and beat that pressure
with a with great quarterback play from
the pocket that was where jared
struggled and they they solved that big
time because matt stafford is one of the
best i've ever been around at doing that
exact thing and they pinpointed that
they said we need that i don't care if
we've been to the super bowl we're going
to make our team better and the rams to
their credit they've always made those
moves you know go get jalen ramsey when
we're struggling secondary go you know
do what you got to do to get a player
that's going to take you the next level
and i think they've done that with matt
it's just a matter of can they kind of
bring it all together
still be that same consistent offense
but but when they come down to it they
got to throw the ball and they're in the
pocket he's one of the best in the
league now and so you're not you're not
working at a disadvantage in that
situation anymore he's going to excel
great to talk to you as always david
thanks for joining us and uh we hope to
catch up with you during the season
you too buddy good talking to you that's
david carr nfl network analyst former
nfl quarterback what'd you say 78 times
he was sacked one season yeah he has the
two of the three most sack seasons in
nfl history
can you guess the other guy who's second
randall cunningham that is correct and
randall cunningham played half as many
games to be sacked 70 times as david
carr david carplayed 16 games in 72
sacks i think randall cunningham played
like nine games to be sacked 70 times